حلقه نجوم صف اول وبامتياز فبعمل منجم من
سنوات وعوده النجمات نجم طاش العوده عبد
الله السدحان ضيفنا في تفاعلكم والعمل
النجم جعفر العمده وباحداث ناريه مستمر في
الهيمنه على الترند ومخرج العمل النجم
محمد سامي ضيفنا في الاستوديو اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
طاش العوده من اكثر المسلسلات اللي كانت
منتظره هذا الموسم الدرامي فهو بشكل عوده
لعمل تربى عليه اجيال على مدار سنوات ناقش
خلالهم مختلف قضايا المجتمع السعودي في
اطار كوميدي وصار جزء لا يتجزء من ذاكره
السعوديين وحتى العرب ورجع لهم هذا
الرمضان بعد انقطاع 12 سنه العمل من بطوله
النجمين عبد الله السرحان وناصر القصبي
اللي شكلوا ثنائيه ولامسوا بادائهم وجدان
وقلب كل محبينهم وفي عشرين حلقه رجعوا لنا
مع طاقم المسلسل او رجعوا لنا مع طاقم
المسلسل الكثير من الذكريات والحنين
وقدموا عمل حصد ارشادات وواسعه
اما بالنسبه لي البصمه اللي تركها طاش
العوده عند المتابعين فيمكننا عنوانها
بالحنين والذكريات وهذه عينه من تعليقات
الناس على المسلسل وحلقاته
ومن الرياض معنا النجم عبد الله السدحان
اهلا فيك معنا وكل عام وانت بالف خير يا
رب
اهلا وسهلا وكل عام وانتم جميعا بالف خير
لمن يعني نقدر نطالع بعد ما انتهت الحلقات
وانتهى العرض وشفنا الردود الفعل وشفنا
الحلقات وشفنا كيف كل شيء كيف عبد الله
السدحان اليوم يقيم طاش العوده
حقيقه التقييم ما هو عندي هو عند المتلقي
هو من القيم اذا انا بقيم فبعطي انفسنا
درجات اقل حقيقه
كنا بحاجه الى تايمنج او وقت بالاصح
اكيد انه العوده باء توقف دائما من 11 او
12 سنه لابد ان يكون في بعض التردد بعض
التخوف من جميع الجوانب يعني سواء انا او
القائمين على العمل او زميلي وصديقي
وحبيبي ابو راكان نفس الشيء يعني كان
عندنا نوع من التوجس لكن بعد انتهاء العمل
لكن هي النقطه الوحيده اللي انا اقدر
اقولها عن طاش ما طاش وتقييم له بغض النظر
عن نجاح حلقه من ضعف حلقه او بالاصح يعني
من متوسط الى جيد الى جيد جدا وما شابه
طاش ما طاش يبقى هو
عمل يلم الاسره هذا من خلال ملاحظتي من
المنازل والبيوت يعني هو العمل الذي
استطاع ان يلم الاسره جميع الصغير والكبير
والوسط وهكذا فهذه ميزه تسجل الى عمل تحت
مسمى طاش طيب من اجابتك يعني خليتني عندي
كذا سؤال بدي اسالك هو اول شيء حضرتك ذكرت
قلت انه صديقي وحبيبي ابو راكان يعني عوده
التعاون مع ناصر القصبي بعد 12 سنه كان
كيف كانت الكواليس بعد هذا
الغياب يعني خصوصا انه في فتره كانت فيها
اخذ ورد وقيل وقالوا خلافات يعني
في خلافات هي خلافات في وجهات نظر على
الانتاج والعمل والشراكه وما شابه وهذه
تحصل في كثير من الشركات والثير من
شركات كبرى بنوك وما شابه هي خلافات بسيطه
وفي مرحله عمريه معينه هذه منتهيه لكن بعد
العوده
حقيقه يعني كاننا امس يعني كان 11 سنه
اختزلت في فتره سبع شهور او ثمانيه شهور
ما حسينا باي شيء يعني يبقى هو عرفني وانا
اعرفه يعني احنا عارفين بعض
وهدفنا في النهايه ان هذه السفينه ان تصل
الى
المرفا او تصل الى بر الامان بشكل مناسب
وجيد
بعض الناس حضرتك زي ما ذكرت قلت انه يعني
انه جيده جدا جيد كل هذا الكلام انه في
تفاوت في الحلقات بعض الناس هذا كان
تعليقها الاساسي انه في تفاوت في مستوى
الحلقات فانت بتتفق يعني مع هذا الموضوع
هل بتعتقد انه هذا شيء يعني عادي او انه
كان كذا في السابق ولا في مشكله يعني
نعم نعم في عادي جدا بالعكس في السابق
اجزاءنا 18 17 16 نزولا
لو حسبنا نكتشف ان هناك خمسه او ست حلقات
متميزه جدا
والاخرى جيد وهكذا في هذا الجزء قد يكون
الجيد جدا اكثر من النسبه اللي كانت
موجوده في الاجزاء السابقه حقيقه يعني لكن
هو ضيق الوقت يعني حقيقه انا اقدر اقول عن
طاش العوده مثل الكويز الاختبار المفاجئ
او الامتحان المفاجي في قاعه الامتحانات
او في قاعه الكليه او الجامعه لما الدكتور
يقول لك
طلعوا ورق واكتب عندك امتحان الان اختبار
سؤال مفاجئ مهما كان امامنا وقت لكتابه
النصوص او انشاء ورشه نص لكن
لا نستبعد النفسيه الحاله السيك لكل شخص
فينا سواء قال لي اقصد المشاركين في ورشه
النص
من هو جديد على هذه الورشه ومن هو من
اعتاد على هذه الورشه اضافه الى انه
ينظرون نظره اخرى انه عبد الله وناصر كيف
يعني كان هذا الشغل الشاغل لكن ابو راكان
وعبد الله اكبر من هذه الامور
مرحله متجاوزه وتم تجاوزها بكل اريحيه
وبكل بساطه بس ما تحس انه يعني بعد هذه
الخبره كلها انكم لازم تطمحوا انه الحلقات
تكون كلها ممتازه
باذن الله نطمح دائما لكن
عفوا لما انا اقول حلقه تقريبا مستوى جيد
انا اتكلم عن وجهه نظر معينه انا اسمعها
لكن في اخرين يرون انها جيد جدا
تفاوت واختلاف الاراء هذا الهدور اساسي
يعني انا ما ارى اي حلقه ضعيفه اجد هذه
الحلقه مثلا بدون مسميات لانه والله عندي
في البيت مثلا الميرون انها متوسطه انا
اسمع ردود فعل اخرى ان من اروع الحلقات
الله اجي اسمع هذه الحلقه لا هذه والله ما
كانت جيده اسمع الله هذه اجمل حلقه يعني
نتفاجى بردود الفعل لانه الاراء تتباين
وتختلف الكريمه طيب خليني اقول لك لموضوع
اخر اللي هو عن المخرج عامر الحمودي اللي
هو نشر تغريده كان بيحتاج فيها على
عرض المسلسل
والعوده او طاش العوده وخلينا الان احنا
الان بنشوف على الشاشه يعني يعتبر الموضوع
انتهاك الحق الادبي والفكري وانه صاحب حق
بحكم من محكمه الاستئناف الاداريه بمنطقه
الرياض وانه انتم ما كان فيكم تستخدموا
كلمه طاش مره اخرى في العنوان كيف بترد
على هذا الكلام
اولا لا تعليق بني مطول في التعليق هذا
اخذنا ولدتين وعجلنا في جهات معينه هي ترى
هذا الموضوع الى هل راي ثانيا انا وبركان
لا نتعدى في هذا الجزء ممثلين يعني مقابل
اجر معين نقدم عمل مشتاق لهالمشاهد فهذه
قضيه ما تهمني انا ولا يهمني
القرقعه الكلام وكثر الحكي يعني مو موضوعي
وهم المشاهد
بقدر ما احنا نضيع في وقت
ايه هو موضوع جدلي خلينا نقول انه لما
انكتب التغريده صار عليه جدال بس طيب خلاص
وصلت رسالتك لهذا الموضوع خليني كمان يعني
اعرض لك تغريده ثانيه للناقد رجا ساير
المطيري كان بيقول فيها انه طاش المشروع
يجب ان يستمر انه مهما كان مستواه ولازم
يتحول لزي
اللي مستمر صار له خمسين سنه وناجح جدا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وطبعا حول
العالم ايضا هل ممكن نتوقع انه في جزء
ثاني ويستمر هذا المشروع
العلم عند الشيوخ حقيقه يعني هم من جمعنا
وهم من
اسسوا طاش العوده وهذا الفكره
العلم عند ابو ناصر تحديدا يعني انا اتوقع
ابو ناصر
والشيخ ابراهيم
وانا قلت ما فيه نعم يعطيهم الصحه
والعافيه انا واثق انهم بدلوا قصاره جهدهم
وليست القضيه هي ماليه بقدر ما هي حتى
نفسيه لانه
توقف 11 سنه واعاده عمل ويلقى ردود فعل
متباينه وجميله شيء يعتبر انجاز لهم الشكر
حقيقه معالي المستشار ابو ناصر تركي ال
الشيخ الشيخ وليد الابراهيم
حقيقه لهم دور فعال وهم اعتبرهم الابطال
خلف الكواليس لكن لما نرجع الى
عطاش على تغريده اخي والاستاذ رجع
انا قلت في بدايه اللقاء انه طاش هو اصبح
جزء من الموروث الشعبي السعودي لا اتوقع
انه عبد الله السد او ناصر القصبي في هذه
المرحله او بهذا العمر بحاجه الى شهره او
اضواء او ما شابه لا احنا المهم عندنا
كفنانين صادقين برساله لنحملها هو ارضاء
المتلقي وحقيقه انا يهمني لم الاسره انا
لست ضد الاعمال الاخرى بالعكس انا اشجع
على ان يكون هناك اعمال اخرى سواء قبل طاش
او 14 او ما يكون في طاش وكانت في 11 سنه
منحت هذه فرصه للجميع لاثبات وجودهم وظهر
ممثلين رائعين واسماء جميله سواء من
الجنسين حقيقه لكن لما نتكلم انا من وجهه
نظري انه اصبح طاش موروث شعبي موروث سعودي
الجميع يشاهد من المغرب العربي الى الخليج
اذا ما دخلنا في بعض الدول الاخرى فهو جزء
لا يتجزا من الحياه يعني انا لا انسى
اتصالات زمان يقول ما كنا نعرف عن
السعوديه الا مكه لكن من خلال طاش عرفنا
البيت السعودي والاسره السعوديه والمجتمع
السعودي الحقيقي وهذا شيء يعني نفتخر فيه
حقيقه
كمان يمكن واحده من اكثر الحلقه كفيت ولا
تبيني اكمل لا يعني انت وفيت وفيت بس انه
ما اعطتني اجابه واضحه انه اذا بتتكلموا
على جزء ثاني ولا لا الصراحه هل ناقشوكم
طيب
ما تكلمنا حقيقه
لا لا لكن انا مثل ما تفضلت أنا
همي هو المتلقي همي هي الاسره يعني طاش
مثل ولا بدي التجاعيد
قالوا لك الان لو جو
لو قالوا لك الشيوخ تعال في نشتغل على جزء
ثاني السنه الجايه حتقول اوكي
اكيد اني لا يمكن بقول لهم انتم فصلوا
وانا البس لكن حيكون لي بعض الشروط
البسيطه اللي هي في النص لابد ان يكون لنا
ورشه النص يكون لنا دور فيها رئيسي ومهم
بركان لانه في ورشه النصف في الاعمال
السابقه من طاش ما طاش او كل كل عيال قريه
كنا رئيسيين في ورشه النص ونخيطه ودائما
الثنائيات جميله يعني انا من خلال ردود
الفعل اللي انا سمعت عن طاش العوده انه
الحلقات اللي فيها ثنائيات كانت هي
الجميله حقيقه لانه في تناغم كبير اللي
فيها الحنين اعرفوا ايش يبي وهو يعرف وش
انا
ما بغض النظر عن الحنين لا احنا عارفين
بعض يعني
صح ايوه
بس انا كنت
حابه عملت صدى مره كبيره للحلقه اللي
تكلمتوا فيها عن المخدرات اللي حتى وزير
الاعلام سلمان الدوسري ايضا غرد اعنه
شايفين الان تغريدته على الشاشه ومدحها
بشكل كبير وهي لاقت استحسان كبير من الناس
هذه الحلقه تحديدا انتم كنتم مهتمين فعلا
انكم توصلوا فيها هذه الرساله تحديدا يعني
صحيح مهم جدا وهذا لا تنسين اني انا قبل
لاسره ولله الحمد
وكذلك اعتبر كل شباب هذا الوطن ابنائي
حقيقه من الجنسين فهذه الافهة
وخواتها يعني حقيقه شيء مدمر يعني وانا
حنا قاعدين نسمع ونقرا ونشوف
نتائجها فيجب ان تتضافر الجهود اكثر واكثر
للتوعيه لكن بطريقه غير مباشره بطريقه
تداعب المشاعر هذا اللي انا اقصد طيب نحن
شاكرين لك في ظهورك معنا اليوم وطبعا الف
مبروك
العمل والف مبروك هذه العوده وشكرا انك
خصصت لنا هذا الوقت كل عام وانت بالف خير
كان معنا طبعا من الرياض النجم الكبير عبد
الله السدحان شكرا لك
لما نقول جعفر العمده يعني بنقول المسلسل
رقم واحد وبكل صراحه عربيا في مختلف الدول
العربيه المسلسل مو بس ماخذ اهتمامه
مشاهدات والناس حبته لا المسلسل عامل حاله
مع المشاهدين قليل جدا الاعمال اللي على
مر تاريخها عملتها ومع الحلقات الاخيره
وتصاعد الاحداث الدنيا ولعت على الاخر
وترندات وهشتاغات المسلسل مفجره كل
المنصات وتعودنا انه نشوف اسم المسلسل كل
يوم هاشتاق الترند على تويتر وفيسبوك وعلى
جوجل لو مو اسم المسلسل فاسم شخصيه من
الشخصيات اللي عليها الكلام دائما متصدره
قوائم البحث يوميا وطبعا الموضوع نفسه على
تيك توك اللي هاشتاقات المسلسل عليه جامعه
حتى الان وركزوا لي على الرقم اكثر من
اربعه مليار مشاهده يعني ترى لو احد حيجي
يتناقش انه هل هذا نجاح او مو نجاح اللي
ذكرناه من شويه رد كافي اعتقد يعني
جعفر العمده فعليا تحول عند الناس لحاله
مو بس لمسلسل عادي وهذه مو مبالغه شعور
موجود عند كثيرين سواء اللي بيتفرجوا على
المسلسل او ما بيتفرجوا عليه يمكن المخرج
عمرو سلامه كان من اكثر الناس اللي وصفت
الحاله بدقه انك تحس انه الناس ما بتتابع
جعفر العمده لا الناس بتشجع جعفر العمده
فعليا اللي يفتح اي منصه حيشوف تفاعل مع
الاحداث عجيب خلينا نشوف عينه
اخلاء سبيل جعفر عبدالله واخر
اخلاء سبيل جعفر
[تصفيق]
عليها الحاله
[موسيقى]
في الموعد
اضحك عنيد وسعيد
اضرب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عشان تقعد اجيب اخواتي ولا اجيب احمد
مكاوي ولا اجيب مين بالظبط في الشارع
والله انا معاك يا سيد بس يلا قوم
بالسلامه
وانا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسافر نجاح العمل واهتمام الجمهور فيه من
اول يوم في رمضان فرض علينا تغطيه والكلام
عنه من نجوم واحد واثنين وثلاثه واكثر
كمان واستضفنا كمان بخرجوا النجم محمد
سامي لكن مع كل التطورات اللي صايره موضوع
صار كبر فقلنا محمد سامي لازم يجوا
الاستديو عندنا ونستجبه على اللي بيصير
فهو معنا في الاستوديو فعلا المخرج النجم
محمد سامي اهلا فيك يا محمد
عذبتنا هذا الرمضان تعبتنا
الحمد لله مين ابن محمد رمضان احمد باشا
احمد داش اكيد هادي ما فيهاش دال مش
حتصدمنا في النهايه
مش عارف
احنا محتارين يعني محتارين في اذا هتصدمنا
في النهايه محتارين في بلال شامه ايش رح
تصير نهايته محتارين دلال ايش حتكون
نهايتها محتالين في كثير اشياء وحاسين انك
انت ممكن تغدر فينا في النهايه يعني هو
المسلسل دايما انا بشوف المسلسل لازم يقوم
على التشويق ايوه هو انت شوقتنا هو الحمد
لله والله يعني هو اول حاجه اول جمله نبدا
بها الكلام نقول الحمد لله رب العالمين
النجاح من عند ربنا
سبحانه
اجتهدنا واشتغلنا كويس قوي كلنا ناس كتير
قوي مش شخص او اتنين او تلاته ناس كتير في
كل الاقسام كان في روح في مسلسل جعفر
العمده ورا الكاميرا قدام الكاميرا الناس
عايزه تنجح
ناس عايزه تعمل مسلسل يكون بالنجاح ده ده
راجع لان هو اشتغل مع محترفين وبنشتغل
معنا الشطار الحاجه التانيه ان لله الحمد
ان محمد رمضان ومحمد سامي عملوا مسلسلين
مهمين جدا الاسطوره والبرنس
والمسلسلين دول كان نجاحهم استثنائي
فالناس بقت حاسه ان احنا ممكن نعمل كده
تاني ممكن نعمل اكتر من كده وعرفنا ان
احنا يعني دايما انا ومحمد رمضان بنشتغل
مع بعض بالشكل ده وابقى مع بعض قوي
ففرضنا على كل اللي حوالينا ان هم يكونوا
في عندهم
ان هم يكونوا جوه الروح دي ان هم يدخلوا
الموضوع باستقتال على النجاح
الكرو كان مموت نفسه الكاست كان موت نفسه
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى ده الناتج بيكون عامل
لا هو فعليا السوشيال ميديا يعني اليوم
تحديدا مقلوبه كمان بسبب موضوع جعفر
العمده والس بب كلام بدا يطلع انه نهايه
المسلسل بتتغير وانه صناع العمل قرروا
يعملوا كده لما شافوا انه الناس بتوقعت او
انه توقعت النهايه واستشهدوا بفيديو لصفصف
حبيبتي الملايين خلينا نشوفه بس
الحق بصوا السلاح
يلا
نداء من صفصف النهارده يوم العيد منزلين
لنا بطلوا تعملوا توقعات ما انتم بتتوقعوا
وصفت تشتغل بتتوقعوا الحاجات بتتغير
النهارده ايه بشتغل اهو
عجبكم كده توقعوا اقعدوا بقى
هيحصل ايه وانا اللي بدفع الثمن ماشي كله
وانتم طيبين
كل سنه وانت طيبه يا ست الكل ماشي يا
حبيبتي
طيب الناس انقسمت تمام شيء بيقول محمد
سامح يغير النهايه وش بيقول ما حد يتغير
النهايه اكيد ولعت الدنيا في النقاشات
طيب يعني
حتتغير النهايه من جد لا طب ايش الفيديو
انا في مشهد من المشاهد عندي حاجه تكنيك
اللي عايز اخدها يعني عايز اخد زوايا
تانيه في مشهد
فطلبت ان انا اصور المشهد اصور جزء من
المشهد تاني
مدام هلا بتهزر فهو الفيديو اتاخد للمنظر
ده لما هلا بتهزر عشان نازله تصور انا ما
كلمتها بصراحه ما تاخرتش ما كلمت محمد
رمضان ما تاخرش يعني الناس
فهي بتهزر فالناس فهموا ان ان الموضوع
تغيير نهايه انا خايفه انك بس بتقول كده
موجوده النهايه
المشهد اللي انا كنت بصوره ده في حلقه 27
ما لهوش علاقه بالنهايه خالص في النهايه
محسومه طيب كل الكلام الناس بيقولوه
والنهايات اللي جالسين بيتخيلوها طيب مش
مش هتتغير او بتكونش النهايه ما بتكونش
مشهد المسلسل اللي تكون نهايته مشهد تاكدي
ان النهايه بتاعته مش حلوه النهايه بتكون
ايميل نوع من المشاهد احنا جالسين بنبني
بنبني المشاعر لحد ما نوصل لنقطه معينه ما
ينفعش النقطه دي
نحيد عنها يعني
الفيديوهات اللي بيعملوها الناس يعني
فعليا ايش بتحس لما بتشوفها يعني والله
والله بفرح قوي بفرح جدا وبفرح ما اعظم من
الفنان يقدم عمل ويتعب ويشقى فيه ويلاقي
ان ده رد الفعل عند الناس ويلاقي كل هذا
النجاح والحب والتقدير يلاقي الموضوع عدى
مرحله المسلسل ودخل في مرحله انه بقى
تعايش عامل البيوت والاسر مستوا الوطن
العربي وكل بلدان الوطن العربي طب دي اعظم
حاجه ممكن يقبلها الفنان في حياته ساجد
لله بقى ويقعد يشكر في ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
قدر ما ما يستطيع
تحس انه نجاح جعفر العمده الان تخطى
البرنس والاسطوره
كلهم اولادك انا عارفه بس انه فاهم قصدي
حضرتك اه جعفر العمده طبعا عبد البرنس
والاسطوري
بعده والله زي ما عملنا الاسطوره
الناس سالت هتعملوا ايه بعدي وربنا كرمنا
سبحانه وتعالى وعملنا البرنس وكان بالشكل
ده
والحمد لله ربنا وفقنا فيه ما جينا نعمل
المسلسل ده قلنا محمد رمضان قال وانا قلت
قبل المسلسل قلنا الناس ان شاء الله نجاح
يفوق البرنس والاسطوره وفعلا احنا عملنا
كده
وانت خليتيني بقت زيك اقول البرنس
هو مسلسل البرنس
هو البرنس صح انا في البرنس
كان كان صعب قوي انك تعدي الاسطوره برضه
وفي في جعفر العمده صعب قوي انك تعدي
البرنس
اجتهاد اجتهاد اجتهاد اجتهاد اجتهاد
نشوف ايه اللي كان ناقص هنا ونزود عليه
وايه الحاجات اللي هنا هو في في نوع من
الناس لما بينجح
ما بيشوفش اخطائه ويفرح جدا ويقول والله
انا كل حاجه كانت صح في نوع من الناس لما
بينجح طبعا
المسلسل في جعفر العمده لا مش معقولش عن
اخطاء عن اخطاء الناس مش دوري اقول عن
اخطاء الناس اخطائي ليا انا عالجها فده
حاجات بتاعتي داخليه تمام انا في قمه نجاح
اي مسلسل انا ببقى شايف العيوب وبكتب
وبكتب حاجات كتير جدا عشان في المسلسل
اللي بعده بشتغل عليها اكثر
واحسنها انا في جعفر العمده شايف اني
بدايه من النص وهو اساس المساله السكريبت
واساس المساله اللي انت كاتبه انا ومهب
طارق انا قصه وانا ومهاب طارق سيناريو
وحور
انا شايف اني كانت توفيق من عند ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى اني انا نجحت ان انا اعمل
حاجه في جعفر العمده
في بناء قصته وهي دي اللي عملت التفاعل
اللي مع الناس مش فكره الله مسلسل حلو انا
بتفرج عليه التفاعل اللي ما بين الناس
والسكرين اتعمل عن قصد اني انا قررت في
المسلسل ده اني اخلي الجمهور بطل
قررت في المسلسل ده ان الجمهور مش يبقى
متفرج الجمهور يبقى مشارك
باني انا اقدم قصه
يبدو بالنسبه لك للوهله الاولى انك سابقه
تفكيري وانك عارفه ان سيف هيطلع ابنه وانا
ببينه في حلقه خمسه في المسلسل انا مصرح
قبل المسلسل مع
اعلامي رامي رضوان اني فكره المسلسل مبنيه
على شخص بيدور على ابنه وابنه قدامه طول
الوقت
فانت حاسه كمشاهد في الاول ان انت عرفتي
حاجه ما حدش عارفها غيرك حاسه انك تعرفي
القصه دايما وقريبه لها بس حاسه ان كانك
شايفه حاجه وقاعده تجري منك وقاعده تجري
ورا زي بلال شامه بالظبط محمد رمضان طب
المشاركه بتاعت ليه الجمهور بطل لان بطل
العمل
نورتينا
وطبعا عندك مسلسل كمال ناجحه مبروك انت
كمان النجاح على العلاقه مشروعه ميرسي جدا
الله يبارك فيك وطبعا انت اليوم يعني
عامله مداخله معانا علشان كمان انت كمان
تهني محمد يعني على النجاح اكيد انت
بتتابعي جعفر العمده بس انت يمكن عارفه
النهايات عارفه النهايه انت
ما اقدرش اقول حاجه يعني
اكتر حد انا باخد معاك طول الوقت وكده
مختلف في هذا المسلسل ليش الناس كده توحدت
معاهم
الو ايوا سمعتنا
يا مي
عن المسلسل انه ايش اللي شايفته قد كده
يعني مخلي الناس متوحده معاه الدرجه
انا طبعا عايزه ابارك لمحمد لان يعني هو
مش يعني النجاح الكبير ده مش جديد عليه هو
مخرج مبدع والحقيقه ان هو عمل نجاحات
كبيره قوي قبل كده في البرنس وفي الاسطوره
وفي مع فك الاسرار ويعني حاجات كتير قوي
فالحمد لله يا رب على نجاح السنه دي
وهو مسلسل حلو اوي مكتوب حلو قوي
وقفلات الحلقات قويه جدا يعني انت طول
الوقت ايه اللي هيحصل طول الوقت مغضوضه
على على البطل وعايزاه في حاجات كتير هو
مش عارفها انت عايزاه يعرفها
هو المسلسل يعني هو جيد الصنع من كل حاجه
يعني كل حاجه فيه معموله صح سواء اداء
ممثلين سواء كتابه سواء تصوير كل حاجه صح
لو كنت هتشاركي في المسلسل يا مي كنت
هتاخذي اي دور اي دور تحبيه دور جاف
بلال شامه
روحي
ما عندك دور معيد تحبيه مثلا
هو اي دور مع محمد حلو يعني الحقيقه ان كل
الادوار معاه دائما يعني اكيد حتقول لك
اوكي الحقيقه بجد كل الاضناك كل نجمه في
المسلسل كلهم نجوم صح ايا كان حجم العمل
الدور اللي بيعملوه هو كلهم نجوم مش بحجمه
لا لا
فعلا المسلسل كل اللي موجودين فيه نجموا
يعني وصاروا ترندات
فعلا طب انا بشكرك يا مي على هذه المداخله
ومبسوطه وان شاء الله المره الجايه تكوني
معانا في الاستوديو وتنورينا ان شاء الله
شكرا لك
ميمنعرض عليها دور في المسلسل اوكي عشان
يعني من الاساس منه شوفوا انه احنا مش
دايما بنشتغل مع بعض اصلا
دي مختلفه هو كل نجم بيبقى له وقت بيعمل
فيه حاجات معينه دلوقتي بتعمل حاجات
مختلفه مميز دلوقتي بتعمل
في خطوه هي عملت لؤلؤ مسلسلها لوحدها
وعملت السنه اللي فاتت رانيا وسكينه هي هي
هي وروبي وكان مسلسل بطوله الاثنين مع بعض
كان على الام بي سي
والسنه دي لما عملت المسلسل بتاع ياسر
جلال
كان اول حاجه هي وياسر عندهم كم حلوه قوي
مع بعض وعاملين مسلسل فتاوى كان وكان نجاح
جدا تاني حاجه كانت دور قائمه عليه القصه
وقائم عليه الموضوع هو قائم الموضوع على
على هذه العلاقه
انما هي النهارده مش كل الادوار اصبحت
تناسبها او كل الادوار اصبحت ينفع ان هي
تقدمها فهي ما كانش من الاول مطروح فكره
ان هي تبقى موجوده في مسلسل الاربع نساء
زوجته
وان كان اني انا انا السنه دي كان عندي
افكار وهي عندها افكار انما فكره ان الناس
بتقول محمد ومي بيشتغلوا مع بعض فده
يخليني مش عايز اجيبها في العمل ده او
بيخليها مش عايز يشتغل في العمل ده اطلاقا
انا كمان ان شاء الله نازل لا انا عندي
مسلسل انا ومي بنصوره مسلسل مي انا المخرج
بتاعه تاليف مهاب طارق انتاج مها سليم انا
بصوره كمان اسبوع
والله بصي انا انا مش من انصار هي هو
مشروع قائد انا مش من انصار بارتو انا مش
من انصار الفكره بتاعه بارت 2 دي اما انا
كنت اسهل حاجه على فكره لما عملت مسلسل
ادم 2011 كنت اسهل حاجه ادم بارتو اما
عملته مع سبق الاصرار ونجح جدا اعمل حكايه
حياه كنت عملت اي الاسطوره كنا عملنا
البرنس كنا عملنا بتدخل تحدي جديد يعني
انا شايف كده
نجحت جدا بلقلق وكسرت الدنيا بلقلق تقدري
تقدمي انجح من لؤلؤ تقدري تعملي صراحه
عظيم عمل عظيم ولكن هو عشان الانسان لما
يجي في يوم من الايام يبص لمكتبته
تلاقي فيها تنوع ده اعمل 17 جزء من نفس
العمل عشان اعمل نفس النجاح خليني بدي
اسالك شويه اشياء كده على السريع مشكله
التتر صار فيه كلام على التتر احمد قبل
الجميع مش عارف ايش الكلام ده ليش احمد
احمد نجم وكل من بالعمل نجوم اول حاجه
التتر هو يرجع لمحمد السعدي هو منتج العمل
يرجع لشركه ميديا هب هي الشركه المنتجه
للعمل انا مش انا كمخرج انا ليا الاشراف
الفني في منتج التتر والاشراف على شكل
الفونت واشراف على شكل
ترتيب بالظبط وبعدين انا شايف
احمد داش راجل عامل يعني في نفس رمضان
عنده مسلسل بطولته على على شاشه قناه مهمه
مسلسل بطوله احمد باشا النهارده نجم جيله
ومهم ونجم مهم وقصه الموضوع قائمه على
محمد رمضان واحمد باشا الراجل وابنه جعفر
وابنه
انا مش شايف اني حتى لو حصل بعد ان اني
اني اللي حركته تقصديه ان منه قالت من دي
اطيب واحده في العالم ممثله رائعه وانسانه
جميله وهي واحمد اصحابه واخوات
بس وان كان احيانا ممكن الواحد يخونه
التعبير او يخونه الكلام او يبقى طمعان في
شيء اكتر فيلاقي حاجه او هي بتقيسها
بالاقدميه كل ممثل من حقه ان هو يتمنى
ولكن دي في الاخر تعقبات وبتاع ده لا ينقص
من منا ولا يزيد من احمد ولا ينقص من احمد
ولا يزيد منه والاثنين اصحاب واخوات
وزملاء في عمل ناجح وبينهم كل احترام
الجده المستمر على موضوع زينه انت قلت انه
ما عندك اي مشكله مع زينب الكلام هذا كله
زينه طلعت في برنامج الان والتصريحات
عمليه كل مكان تقول ما راح اشتغل مره
ثانيه مع محمد سامي خلينا خلينا ننجح في
مسلسلنا ونتبسط بنجاحه وشوف نجاحه مسلسلنا
وبعدين نبقى نشوف قصه زينه
يزعجها جدا
مش هتشتغل مع محمد سامي ثاني انا في الاخر
عملنا مسلسل ناجح وربنا سبحانه وتعالى
كلامنا فيه ونجحنا واتبسطنا وعملنا شغل
كويس وهي نجحت عملت دور كويس ربنا يسعدها
بنجاحها ويبسطها بنجاحها وده قرار يخصها
هي هي اكيد ليها وجهه نظري انا بحترمها
على كل الاحوال انزعجت انه انت كمان ذكرت
تعاون مي مع روبي انزعجت انه روبي السنه
عندها مسلسل اسمه حضره العمده وانتم جعفر
العمده او على الاقل انزعجت بدايه رمضان
لانه الان يعني خلينا نقول اكيد مش مزعوج
انا هقول لحضرتك هقول لحضرتك اول حاجه
المسلسل ده في حاجه نقطه صعبه جدا مسلسل
ده انتاج ريمون مقار ومحمد محمود عبد
العزيز اصدقائك جدا
وبحترمهم جدا وصلناها شاطرين جدا جدا جدا
وبحبهم من قلبي قوي مش مش حب الدعاء وهم
بيحبوني جدا في رقم واحد انا ما اقدرش
اطلع اقول اي كلمه لان ده مقدرش مش هعرف
اشوفهم لو اتكلمت كلمه انزعجت عشان مصلحه
شغلي بس انه يحصل خلط ما بين مسلسلين
اسمهم العمده
المسلسل بتاعي الاول كان اسمه العمده بس
زودت جعفر عشان يوضح الحاجات يعني انت لما
تقولي شفت العمده النهارده او بتعملي سيرش
على العمده اكيد مش حاجه حلوه يبقى في
مسلسلين بنفس الاسم فانا قلت من الاول قلت
ان انا انزعجت ان ان في مسلسل ولكن ما
اقدرش اتكلم ثاني حاجه روبي صديقتنا
وصديقه مي جدا وانا بحترمها وبحبها واتمنى
لها النجاح
حاجه ازعجتك او عملت لك سببت لك ازعاج
ولكن من اشخاص انت ما ينفعش ابدا ان انت
ولو للحظه تزعليهم لان هم في التاريخ انا
انا عازرهم هو الموضوع كتابته السيناريو
بتاعه قائم على فكره حضره العمده هو قائم
على فكره حضره العمده او قائم على فكره ان
في عمده ست والموضوع عندي قائم على بيت
العمده وعلى العمده اللي هو جعفر العمده
بطل الروايه اللي هو الموضوع كله قائم على
تركيبته
فالحمد لله رب العالمين انا قلت قبل كده
في الاول قلت اني بعد ما يبدا رمضان ان
شاء الله ويبدا اللي عملت تكون موجوده
هيبقى واضح قوي الاعمال واضح اللي عمل ده
واضح والعمل ده واضح جمهور وده لجمهوره
وانا فرحان في الاخر الناس شافت العمل ده
وشافت العمل ده وشافت العمل ده وان في
تنوع ولسه بعد رمضان المشاهدات اكثر واكثر
كمان حتزيد يعني لسه في ناس برجعوا بعد
رمضان يعني لما بيروقوا يعني
انت ما شاء الله بعد رمضان كمان عندك فيلم
لا هارلي مش فيلمي فيلم محمد
الفيلم ايوه كتبت محمد سمير مبروك هو
الفيلم ده لا هو هو عشان بس هم كان الاول
نزلوا الاسم وبعدين الاسم هو الفيلم ده
انا محمد رمضان صديقي جدا
واحنا الاتنين نجاح مع بعض كتير محمد
رمضان في الفيلم انا حصل زي ما نقعد مع
اصحاب ده بيحصل من زمان على فكره يعني
حسين الامام مره حكالي ان كان استاذ حسن
الامام هذا المخرج العظيم
وجيلو من المخرجين العظماء يقعد مع بعض
يتشاور في مشهد ويتشاور في ستراك في حاجات
ويساعدوا بعض في الافلام وعشان كده
الافلام كانت بالشكل ده محمد جه يعمل
الفيلم خد راي وظبطت حاجات معاهم في وزبط
حبه حاجات على مستوى الاصحاب فكان تقديرا
ان هم يحطوا الاسم وبعدين انا حسيت ان ده
في ظلم
المؤلف الاصلي للفيلم فليه يعني احنا مش
عشان
انت اسمك كمان مشهور فخلاص يعني بتسهل
الموضوع انه يصيروا الناس تتذكر اسمك انت
في الموضوع بس كده
وتعبت وعملت شغلها بالعكس انا بتمنى لهم
كل النجاح هم عاملين سنه
وبداوا يحمسونا وبينزلوا لنا الاغاني
ان شاء الله اكيد هم الاثنين رائعين وانت
رائع يا
محمد يعني حمستنا انت مخرج ونجم وكاتب
رائع انت رائع عيش تنحى في رمضان انا بحبك
وبحترمك جدا لانك فعلا بتدي طاقه ايجابيه
ويعني شكرا وانا من الناس اللي بيعملوا
فيديوهات دول بقعد اصرخ في البيت ولا لا
هو نفس الحركات دي ههه
بشكرك يا محمد وكان بعدها المخرج النجم
محمد سامي شكرا لك مشاهدينا انا اعود
والقاكم قريبا ان شاء الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]